antoine bonjour alors le nouveau
gouvernement il a été dévoilé hier soir
mais les nominations elle continue à
moscou tout comme les travaux
parlementaires concernant la réforme
constitutionnelle
alors quelles sont vos dernières
informations oui après le dévoilement la
de la composition du nouveau
gouvernement
hier dans la soirée avec avec certains
noms très importants qui ont été
conservés de l'ancienne équipe telle
sergueï lavrov et sergueï choïgou
respectivement aux affaires étrangères
et à la défense les nominations contenu
mais à des échelons plutôt inférieur
alors on peut citer par exemple michael
mais justin le nouveau premier ministre
qui a choisi pour l'aider pour le
suppléer un nouvel adjoint ainsi qu'un
porte parole il a également apporté
quelques changements dans la structure
dans l'organigramme de l'appareil
gouvernemental sinon on a appris
également que le conseil de la
fédération la chambre haute du parlement
a approuvé la mine la nomination d'un
nouveau procureur général un poste très
important dans l'appareil d'état russe à
propos du projet de loi sur les
amendements constitutionnels voulue par
le président russe vladimir poutine
le cheminement parlementaire continue
toujours mené à vitesse grand v par la
douma dans l'après midi
on saura à quelle date le texte sera
présenté en première lecture à la douma
la chambre basse du parlement et ce sera
très probablement dans les tout
prochains jours
étant donné étant donné la priorité
donnée à l'examen de ce texte
merci beaucoup antoine claireaux en
direct depuis moscou